elvis danke ich diese cool drauf
[Musik]
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer
klitzekleinen server vorstellungen
beziehungsweise blitz survival games und
zwar wollte ich euch den msc pixel dot
net server vorstellen mehr oder weniger
ich bin den gratis entdeckt weil
halbwegs hat natürlich jeder minecraft
da muss irgendwie halbwegs zu kennen
beziehungsweise abonniert haben der hat
sich nun einen server eröffnet der
garten bisschen mag dabei ist egal
mit 6000 slots und immer wenn ich jetzt
irgendwie survival games oder
irgendwelche adventures oder paintball
oder irgendwas spiel werde ich das auf
diesem server hier tun und deswegen
wollte ich euch ganz kurz zeigen jetzt
alles funktioniert falls dass einige
noch nicht wissen ich krieg hier nix für
ich bin nicht mit halbwegs in kontakt
oder ähnliches deswegen mache das ganz
allein aus meinem interesse euch das
ganze ein bisschen näher zu bringen weil
ich das echt cool finde und zwar kommt
man erst mal drauf mit diesen drei teams
quick travel world com & magic lokstedt
man erst mal vor blasen beta also nicht
übels viele schilder die man lesen muss
das sind wirklich und die paar schilder
basta da und sind auch ein paar sachen
sowie ip features und alles aber nicht
zu 1000 regel lieber sich erst mal
durchlesen muss dafür gibt dieses buch
der so heißt ein halt erstmal bekommen
da kann man richtig drauf machen und das
aller guides was ich finde ist die magic
lockt einmal recht einfach sind alle
spieler die hier sind sind weg weil das
finde ich besonders gut weil immer wenn
man sich irgendwelche schilder durch
lesen will oder irgendwie sowas da dann
stehen da immer übels viele leute vor
und war selbst überhaupt nicht ab im
chat kann übrigens auch nicht da
schreiben also biss haben dass ein paar
leute was geschrieben das wir sind so
leute die halt hier rechte haben oder
wie man kann ja auch haustiere haben ich
weiß nicht wie man die krise hat das
erst mal drauf gegangen aber das ist das
haustier von löw also sehr niedlich und
jetzt würde ich sagen gehen wir uns mal
quick travel gibt hier mein lobby also
mein lobbyist ihr das hier alles da oben
und so
so und jetzt gehen wir doch mal in blitz
survival gamestar kann landen dann
einfach auf das schwert klicken und dann
freuen wir uns eben hier hin
dann sehen wir hier schon eine komplette
wand was man was da es gibt das sechste
wm
denkbar auch das ist jetzt auch vip also
ich bin nicht wieso wo sind denn wo
kommen wir denn noch so räumen sollen wo
sind denn ein paar leute da so jetzt
sind wir hier sieben leute die hier in
der lobby sind und warten und dann geht
es gleich los also das füllt sich jetzt
langsam und eilig also elf sind wir
jetzt gleich steht das 12 und ja das
fühlt sich jetzt mit der zeit und das
ist halt erstmal die lobby der mann drin
ist ist einfach nur so ein stumpfer raum
wo dann alles schön warten können und
gleich den wir alle auf die map und ich
weiß nicht ob ich blitze weil wir jetzt
jetzt richtig interpretiere
aber ich glaube mein gott hat einer luca
mit k geschrieben dass echte strafe dem
antwort ich nicht kann kraft und mein
gott könnte dich schreiben mein gott
und zwar ist blitz dabei will ich glaube
ich dass man direkt in der map drin ist
und direkt geht's los also glaube ich
weiß es nicht
ich teste mal ganz kurz ich bin 09 sind
580 uns also in zehn sekunden gehts los
ich weiß nicht ob es richtig
interpretiert habe wir können einfach
mal gucken 21
ja okay doch nicht ich dachte wir
starten direkt einfach so da aber wer so
müssen wir ein bisschen warten
das los geht also hier sind auch coole
features ich spiele zum ersten mal und
server hat so mit mir so ein bisschen
zum ersten mal erkunden ich als nicht
konkret ließ man mich regt das recht auf
wenn man wenn man einerseits ich
schreiben kann regt es mich auf aber
wenn man dann auch noch meinen namen
fall schreiben kann
you'll be able to move ach so dann ist
es normal doppelt schlimm so wollen wir
direkt runter laufen oder wollen wir
erstmal zu den kisten ich weiß es nicht
also es läuft auf jeden fall super im
gegensatz zu anderen servern bekommt man
hat hier hinein
ergon hd läuft natürlich auch relativ
gut aber im gegensatz zum nas servern
die haie zum beispiel sind hier nicht
übel aus den lecks und auch nicht
übelste bugs bei problemen wird zum
beispiel
es geht los
geht es jetzt eigentlich ich weiß nicht
ob direkt schon pvp aus ist pvp alles
oder nicht habe ich schlecht keine
ahnung hat doch man kann schon schlagen
glaube ich egal ich hoffe erstmal ein
bisschen durch und versucht dann
irgendwie mich zu mehr oder weniger bis
hin zu retten
kommt da einer kommt keiner her gut dann
erzähle ich jetzt erstmal runde dass
sachen hühnchen das kann ich erst noch
entfalten
so und dann die zier und das zum thema
das wir ein bisschen
julia teams und fürs handy ach so ja gut
cool man kriegt nach derzeit so die alte
mal das ja cool alter von wo
[Musik]
lobby also also das hab ich jetzt
endlich verstanden wie wie sowieso wurde
getötet
da spielen wir mal was anderes jetzt bin
ich wieder auf irgendwas gegangen lobby
oder wir gehen wir noch mal ganz kurzen
zu weisen dass ich relativ kulant solche
komischen ist ich nie so gut aber naja
so wir sind fünf leute hier drin ich
hoffe jetzt schon ein paar mehr ich habe
gerade dadurch bekommen
[Musik]
ok
ja gut acht leute von 24 ich mache meine
kleinen karte wenn ich nicht vergessen
wenn ich zwei gäste samt so freuen wir
haben noch zehn sekunden ist das spiel
startet ich glaube es sind 20 leute wer
da so mancher schwere gleich mit man uns
das traurig ich glaube ich doch erst
mitte dann laufe ich da lang da kann man
da überhaupt dann hoffe ich weiß
garnicht crazy ja gut wir sind
3 wieso nennt man sich bitte einfach nur
eine zahlenkombination bei minecraft der
kurze coupé
[Musik]
los gehen
gut aber er kennt mich auch nicht dass
er auch gut aber okay wir haben die
physiker noch ich glaub so 20 sekunden
ca oder 10 10 sekunden
ok ich glaube erstmals in dieser kiste
da der da und dann hab ich da wieder hin
und dann hoffe ich dass mir keiner daher
läuft natürlich erstmal runde soll schon
der runde werden die über zehn minuten
jetzt geht
[Musik]
schnell weiter jungs weiter geht weiter
jetzt da man hat jeder ist eigentlich
diese diese dass das so schnell ist also
wie ich schon gesagt mehr maps sind alle
von heyl pixel sieht man schon
sie sind relativ kalt ich mag solche
offenen webs viel lieber als diese
ganzen maps die ganzen leute meint alles
einfach alles zu klatschen
jetzt mal was man mir meine schuhe glück
[Musik]
x5 überhaupt gibt es hier ist aus
man muss eine vernünftige waffe drin
sein da war doch noch so ist hier nicht
noch irgendwas nicht nichts leute
schreibt man bitte in die kommentare
wenn ihr richtig schließen weil wir
games wollt wenn ich habe wieder richtig
bock hier drauf ich habe überhaupt kein
turbo memory oder hinten sind auch leute
die jetzt hat die natur bowling ist das
komisch schreibt mir einfach mal wenn
ihr richtig viel zu weit wie gamespot
weil hier macht das echt spaß ich möchte
jetzt nicht irgendwie dass der server
nächster zeit übel zu erfüllt wird und
ich dann nicht mehr aufnehmen kann
aber naja vielleicht kommen die menge
ist weiß nicht also jetzt dadurch dass
er die klausurphase vorbei ist was jetzt
aber irgendwie anschneiden wollte
schreibt mir mal wenn ein extra video
wollte wie ich sage die einzelnen
klassen waren was ich machen musste in
deutsch zum beispiel oder in englisch
und latein oder irgend sowas weil einige
von euch sind dann 13 14 so hauptteil
und die ja machen ja bald auch gegen die
in der oberstufe also in der
einführungsphase nennt sich das bei uns
also dementsprechend ist das zehnte
klasse um sich dann für die elftal
zwölfte klasse vorzubereiten oberstufen
da müssen ihre fächer wählen da kann ich
euch ein paar tipps geben wie ich habe
relativ viel falsch gemacht habe ich
jetzt darüber informiert und realisiert
das ist eine menge falsch gemacht hat
beim wählen ist tot
[Musik]
ja er habe sogar ein schwert ich hoffe
nur dass jetzt keiner mehr kommt hier um
die ecke ihnen gehört warum es noch eine
kiste
komme ich dahin
[Musik]
ja ist das jetzt besser sodass ihr
besser als das weiß ich gar nicht
leute ich suche erst mal ein kleines
plätzchen wo ich mir die ganzen sachen
packen wir sie nicht mal so ein bisschen
sortieren und ordnen eine kiste sehe ich
gerade im blick haben blickt das ist das
auge das ist peripheres sehen freunde
paris ja meine stimme es übrigens oft
folgenlos weil ich gerade erst
aufgewacht bin und direkt ihren pc
gesetzt hat und ich bin wirklich mit der
motivation aufgewacht leute du nimmst
jetzt videos auf so bin ich aufgewacht
und das war so ein cooles gefühl habe
ich mir gedacht das macht so spaß hier
ich glaube immer wenn man ein bisschen
sprintet kriegt man zur geschwindigkeit
oder oder liegt das irgendwann mir das
ist so geil
dahinter typ
der bessere sachen als ich
jetzt freu' mich beide cool
[Musik]
und ich kann ja jetzt hakt es bei mir
genau sehr fair
[Musik]
ja ich hasse zweierteams einfach das
richtig geht
[Musik]
scheiße ich habe gehofft dass da jetzt
ein geiles schwer drin gewesen wäre war
es aber nicht
scheiße scheiße so freude was ist besser
ein holzschwert oder allerdings axt und
was passiert wenn die 20 sekunden davor
bei sind die der rechtsstaat unterlaufen
ich hoffe mal dass wir dann irgendwie
teleportiert werden weil er dann in der
mitte sind
nein ich war ja betrieb sein muss
verpisst euch nein nein lasst mich in
ruhe was ist dann blitzt und blitzt da
was ist das okay drei schlägen drei
schläge her gut sicher gleich ist er ja
das oder das andere
steinachs oder holzschwert soll jetzt
mal einfach so machen wir da drauf gehen
die man sonst ja auch in einer gewissen
form ihm gelang weil ich hier die runde
die da hinten sind 2
das 100
und da ist ein container
okay vielleicht kann ich mich verlieben
verbinden dreh dich um du dich um du
dich um
richtig um deutlich um junge oder soll
ich einfach mal auf den drauf gehen
jetzt von hinten
haha was geht
golde mountain nepal posten jetzt thema
vor okay ich hatte eigentlich teams aber
sonst werde ich mich nicht mit den
verbünden würde wäre ich selber vor dass
opfer und wird dann direkt stemmen oder
soll ich gleich auf die draufgehen dass
er über sie ich habe was damals als ich
noch die beats mit geguckt habe und
selber so videos geguckt haben die bei
days at ihren kumpanen da einfach
angenommen dass man nicht auch relativ
asi
was heißt denn dass dieses komische
herzchen hab ich die auch schon gar
nicht im kopf
unter dir
ich habe sonst noch was nehme ich
brauche wenn schon
wenn schon brauche ich jetzt ein
kräftiger kerl dann könnte ich für
brötchen waren am 23
[Musik]
report
soweit okay dem hinterher
das cool war das ein engländer oder
amerikaner die kennen mich halt nicht
deswegen weiß ich dass du mich nicht
fragen werden aufgehalten oder üblich in
der aufnahme das hat natürlich an so
anderen servern
denn ihr team wir sind ein team bilden
eine familie
[Musik]
ok ich weiß zwar nicht was dieser blitz
dar ist aber na gut
warum schießen fontaine raus axel jeher
als wären solche bergsteiger und woher
der tipp seine ach so das sind diese
raketen da die kommen werden dingsbums
[Musik]
wenn man halt überleben da ist mein gott
ist das komisch zu quatschen dem ball so
zu zocken
okay ich hab mal kurz die lage hier
jungs
[Musik]
red
[Applaus]
danke ich diese cool drauf wo lange
jetzt jungs haben schon platten haben
gesehen doch nicht das so eigentlich ist
das voll geil so die beiden gucken da so
nach ich stehe so wache so ob sie so
einer kommt die kontrollierte in der
galaxie far far away ok wohin das ding
ja ok frisst was gut noch fünf spieler
live ich bin mit drei leuten im team
[Musik]
das heißt dass nicht fest
heißt das wort display
[Musik]
dem kann ich nur noch geben
handy am ohr
ich weiß nicht
[Musik]
austin der sommer stehen bleiben
stones wort
[Musik]
was er denn hin gelaufen
er wartet doch jetzt hat ein schwert für
dich
man hat gar antike helden der was soll
denn voll voll angst vor uns nach den
harten stein schwert ach so
was kann ich mir noch so hier was gibt
ihnen noch ihren freunden
ja
was los
ripley hält ja ok
[Musik]
loosli daher
los ich möchte in kiel bitte ich möchte
auch mal einige töten er hat sogar
bessere sachen als ich alter der künftig
locker einfach umdrehen und mich töten
und ich glaube der realisiert dass
hinter mir noch zwei andere sind
wenn er sich jetzt einfach umdrehen
würden nein afag ich wusste ich wusste
ich wusste dass der westen ausgerüstet
ist backwaren hätte ich mal auf den
anderen gewartet
alles war gut freunde das war es erstmal
hier auf pixel server 1.6 punkte
ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen wenn ich
so weit wie dem spiel werde welche das
auf jeden fall immer hier tun 6000 slots
gehen auch erst mal nicht ganz so
schnell voll
und sonst halt was kann man ja noch
solche spielen the walls quaid kraft das
wäre auf jeden fall spielen und
paintball warfare werdet ihr aussehen
und das wasser erst mal für diese folge
sehen zunächst eine positive bewertung